Тиснява  на українсько-польському кордоні.
Так нещодавно українці масово залишали Польщу,
в тому числі тисячі заробітчан.
Виїхали, за різними оцінками,
від 5 до 20 відсотків працівників.
Через пандемію коронавірусу  ситуація з роботою стала важко прогнозованою.
Яскравий приклад - звільнення на найбільшому у світі
заводі бритв для гоління Gilett у Лодзі.
Вакансій стало однозначно менше.
Так як тут багато закладів стоїть...
Навіть на великих фірмах: із Gilette
пішло скорочення працівників,
із Gilette прийшов працівник, якого я працевлаштував,
і сказав, що там теж було скорочення.
Раніше працювали по 12 годин,
а тепер їх перевели на 8.
Фірма величезна, і скоротили багато працівників.
Вакансій стало однозначно менше.
Щодо сільського господарства,
то в Польщі ось-ось розпочнеться сезон збору спаржі.
За словами рекрутера Фесенка,
надходять цікаві пропозиції і для українців,
але місцеві фермери цього року більше розраховують на поляків,
що так само, як і українці, на тлі пандемії повернулися додому - з Німеччини:
Шукають людей на роботи.
Але зараз це тяжко.
Та навіть якщо бракуватиме українців на ці роботи,
бо зараз їх багато виїхало з Польщі,
то, я думаю, що будуть залучати поляків.
Але там вже ставка буде інша за годину праці.
Утім, за словами іншого експерта,
самі поляки не захочуть іти на такі роботи.
І без українців на польських фермерів чекають великі втрати.
І не дуже захочуть туди іти й поляки.
У них будуть великі проблеми.
І вони стосуються не тільки сільського господарства,
а й сфери будівництва,
де зупиняються будмайданчики,
де достатньо лише однієї людини, яка захворіла,
і всіх відправляють на карантин.
Карантинні заходи треба перетерпіти.
Звісно, якщо йдеться про сезонну роботу,
час не поставиш на гальмо.
Я впевнений, що фермери втратять дуже багато.
В'їзд іноземцям Варшава заборонила поки до 13 квітня.
Польські фермери сподіваються, що уряд незабаром спростить умови в'їзду
для українських заробітчан, інакше галузь чекають незворотні збитки.
Уу зв'язку з карантинними заходами у польських фермерів
усе буде дуже погано.
В дійсності все, що стосується людей
там, де масово не приховати,
на всіх цих роботах були дуже великі проблеми,
я думаю, сезон спаржі вони втратять.
У німецьких фермерів схожі проблеми -
тут недорахуються не лише українських, але й польських сезонних працівників.
Неподалік від Потсдама поблизу кордону з Польщею
Луц Кляйнерт вирощує спаржу.
Цього року 10 польських сезонних працівників до нього не приїдуть.
Свої послуги пропонують німецькі волонтери.
Але фермер сумнівається, що студенти, пенсіонери
чи безробітні впораються із важкою працею на полі.
Ці люди були професіоналами. Вони чудово збирали спаржу.
Аби зібрати таку ж кількість,
мені потрібно замість одного
такого працівника взяти двох нових людей.
Це означає, що видатки на зарплату доведеться подвоїти.
Але я не думаю, що клієнти готові платити мені за спаржу
на 40-50 відсотків більше.
Спаржа приносить цій фермі від 40 до 60 тисяч євро -
найбільший прибуток першої половини року.
Поляки отримували мінімальну в Німеччині зарплатню -
9 євро 35 центів на годину,
а ще - премію залежно від зібраної кількості спаржі.
Шукати і навчати нових робітників Луц Кляйнерт вважає недоцільним.
Каже, краще лишити врожай незібраним:
Я весь час ловлю себе на думці: нехай спаржа просто росте.
Якщо її не збирати - зекономлю на персоналі.
Німецький фермер сподівається, що заробітчанам дозволять приїхати бодай у червні.
Це буде сезон збору фруктів, зокрема полуниці.
Загалом у Німеччині у сільському господарстві бракує
300 тисяч сезонних працівників.
В уряді ФРН розмірковують про спрощення в'їзду для сезонних працівників.
Є ідея впустити людей і розмістити їх, скажімо, під домашнім карантином
у готелях, які стоять порожні,
а через 14 днів подивитися і провести тести.
Цю пропозицію, звичайно, спершу треба оцінити
в контексті політики охорони здоров'я.
Але що точно не годиться, це просто сказати:
ми пустимо всіх і розмістимо їх у притулках масового типу.
Це великий ризик інфікування.
Поки ж, за словами німецького міністра праці,
тимчасово збільшено ліміт перебування для тих сезонних працівників,
які вже перебувають на території країни -
від 70 до 115 днів.
Однак суттєвих послаблень навряд чи можна чекати до кінця карантину.
Тим часом проблемою нестачі сезонних працівників переймаються й у Брюсселі.
Європейська комісія рекомендувала урядам країн спільноти,
аби сезонним працівникам першочергово потрібних спеціальностей,
як-от лікарів та аграріїв, полегшили перетин кордону,
проводячи екстрені перевірки стану здоров'я.